when you work for the SCP Foundation you
need to be ready for anything that's one
as part of the elite foundation training
regiment senior researchers and guards
are always running tests he even against
things that aren't recorded anomalies
under the auspices of the foundation
that's why today for a real change of
pace here at SCP explained we're not
talking about the SCP Foundation we're
talking about made-up monster stories
crowdsourced over the Internet we're
seeing how the foundation might fare
against iconic Creepypasta monsters and
Maniacs like Herobrine Jeff the Killer
the Slenderman Eyeless Jack smile dog
and many many more we've even created
all new mobile task courses to take each
one down so could any of them best the
foundation's best and brightest let's
take a look and find out and be sure to
tell us which is your favorite
Creepypasta entity down in the comments
below let's get creepy Jeff the Killer
first up we've got everyone's favorite
disfigured knife-wielding homicidal
teenager whether it's his terrifying
Visage or the iconic go to sleep
catchphrase that's forever carved into
your mind there are probably a lot of
people out there who have lost nights of
sleep worrying that this pale-faced
monster could be crawling through their
window but we know what you're probably
wondering isn't Jeff just a serial
killer why would the SCP Foundation use
up its time chasing down any old regular
human murderer we'd ask for you to think
again Jeff has displayed Feats that
clearly Mark him as anomalous despite
suffering debilitating Burns to his face
and body he still shows superhuman
strength agility and durability he's
also able to see without eyelids
suggesting some Supernatural element is
at play victims have also reported him
dodging shotgun blasts while stalking
prey so how would the foundation catch
him seeing as Jeff's modus operandi is
breaking into the homes of his victims
while they sleep the best method would
be staking out a neighborhood where he's
been shown to be active keeping close
observations on how sources and even
setting up Personnel from mobile task
force Sigma 9. my name is JF vacant
houses as honey traps Jeff is undeniably
strong fast and tough but if attacked
and surrounded by operatives with
Superior Tactics he could be subdued
without casualties then it would just be
a matter of transferring him to a
standard high security humanoid
containment cell speaking of horrifying
creatures that come to you in the dead
of night The Rake this Supernatural
entity has been around for almost a
thousand years as far as scattered
reports are aware it's also been
reported across four continents and a
huge number of locations within those
continents though most recently it's
been reported in rural New York State
and Idaho in the early 2000s The Rake is
an inhuman Beast most often known for
its large frightening eyes and its Long
brake-like Claws not only does the
monster feed on human beings but it also
produces a traumatic level of fear in
its victims thankfully an entity like
this is far more familiar your territory
for the SCP Foundation using their
state-of-the-art web crawler software
they could catalog reported sightings as
they happen and use clusters of these
sightings to triangulate the location of
the rake and dispatch field agents to
perform reconnaissance missions from
there it would just be a matter of
waiting to strike and sending in Mobile
task force Zeta 13 rake steppers fitted
with Dr Dan's scramble goggles to
prevent them from being affected by the
seemingly Cognito hazardous effects of
viewing the rake when the creature is
placed in containment and kept in a
state of Perpetual bright light it would
simply be a matter of applying a
Scranton reality anchor to prevent the
creature from somehow phasing out of
containment just make sure you avoid its
big staring eyes in the meantime though
that won't be a problem with the next
Creepypasta monster Eyeless Jack this
stealthy creature has its no eyes on one
thing and one thing
your kidneys and unless you want to die
or spend the rest of your life on a
dialysis machine we recommend you keep
your distance from him he's discreet
devious and diabolical and if you wake
up in the middle of the night to see him
staring down at you it may be the last
time your body is able to filter toxins
out of its blood naturally thankfully we
have a way to make the foundation put a
stop to his organ harvesting ways
sometimes to catch a jack you need to
use a jack there's no way to catch
Eyeless Jack without delicious live
kidney bait so we'd recommend sending in
someone who has kidneys to spare Dr Jack
Bright could be the perfect bait without
losing his life luring Eyeless Jack into
a decoy house while mobile task force
gamma 391 Hit the Road Jack prepares to
Spring their cunning trap and plunge
this unpleasant kidney muncher into a
humanoid containment cell forever but
our next Creepypasta entity doesn't on
your kidneys it wants your life Smile
Dog our next entity seems like a
harmless little JPEG to the untrained
eye a little freaky sure but nothing to
lose your mind over but we know that
there's far more to this grinning husky
than meets the eye if some reports are
to be believed this image may even be
connected to the Devil Himself if you're
unlucky enough to see this image in the
world it may already be too late for you
those who see it typically as an email
attachment from a mysterious address
spend the last week of their life in a
hell of the Mind before eventually
succumbing to a bleak and mysterious
death it's a classic Cognito hazardous
image and the most frightening part is
that it's self-propagating with one of
the only ways to even mildly alleviate
the effects seeming to be spreading the
word by subjecting another person to
this nightmare that's when we bring in
Mobile task force row 19 Naughty Dog an
elite group of hardened military
programmers hand-picked from the cia's
cyber warfare unit they used their very
particular set of skills to design web
crawler software that Roots out and
takes down Smile Dog images across the
web and hopefully one day find the
origin of this whole thing the next
creature on the other hand we've given
up on finding the origin of that the
expressionless this entity kind of looks
like a terrifying store window mannequin
except rather than modeling fast fashion
she prefers to swallow cats whole and
murder hospital staff oh and she also
calls herself God his isn't she just so
quirky her primary abilities seemed to
be extreme strength and large sharp
teeth that will easily Rend through
human flesh thankfully not anything the
SCP Foundation hasn't dealt with
countless times before seeing as the
only recorded incident involving the
expression list took place at a hospital
in Los Angeles that would be the most
sensible area to stake out a detail from
the creature's original encounter is
also telling it reacted severely to the
doctor's attempts to sedate it implying
that chemical sedation is an effective
method of incapacitating the beast
that's why every member of mobile task
force Kappa 99 ain't no dummy is a
sharpshooter with a tranquilizer rifle
capable of putting a hippo to sleep with
a single shot she'll probably feel less
like a god in her containment cell but
while this monster is expressionless the
next one has one very notable expression
Mr whitemouth compared to some of our
other Creepypasta the contenders Mr
Widemouth may not look like much but
that our dear friends is exactly what
this nasty little Mal Factor wants you
to think he may look like Gizmo's
slightly demented cousin but his
intentions are even more Sinister than
that of your average Gremlin if you're a
kid home on a sick day Mr Widemouth
might strike up a conversation after
gaining your trust he'll try to lure you
to his special place beyond the trees
for some fun but take it from us all
you'll find out there is your doom this
crafty little creep small stature and
manipulative stealth abilities might
pose somewhat of a challenge for the SCP
Foundation but that doesn't mean they
can't get him with a little intelligence
and elbow grease mobile task force Alpha
18 the smile Smashers will follow
reports of children disappearing from
their isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances then using an extra
strength butterfly net straight from the
folks at Foundation R and D they can
chase down and capture the nasty little
monster but that won't be the case for
this next demonic offering no this
Creepypasta Legend is the one that
captures you
no end house in recent years there's
been a spike in interest in so-called
extreme haunted houses if you're not
sure what these places are like
basically picture a CIA black site with
the occasional plastic skeleton it's all
waterboarding stress positions and car
batteries but even those places are
nothing compared to the nightmare of no
end house it's a moving possibly even
sentient spatial anomaly hiding in a
haunted house attraction and if you find
yourself inside best believe you're
never going to see the outside ever
again thankfully mobile task force Delta
35 mckamey's Bane are on the case around
Halloween every year they use web
crawlers to detect chatter around no end
House events so they can swoop in and
intercept preventing hapless Thrill
Seekers from being devoured by the house
and providing amnestic treatment for
anyone who has too close of a call sadly
the foundation will not be able to
provide refunds for those who already
speaking of paying you'll really pay if
you end up in our next Creepypasta
location of tune abandoned by Disney
mowgli's kingdom an abandoned tropical
Disney attraction based on The Jungle
Book movie is abandoned for a reason
it's a hotbed for anomalous activity
including freakishly large mutant snakes
reports of ghostly activity and most
prominent of all a terrifying photo
negative Mickey Mouse that stalks any
hapless Urban explorers who happen to
find their way onto the site of course
the Walt Disney Corporation keeps it all
hush hush and the SCP Foundation is
happy to give them a hand on that front
even if the frightening photo negative
Mickey was removed from the site it's
likely the other may appear and continue
haunting the site and seeing that the
site cannot be moved as a whole the
foundation's best bet is to form a
perimeter around the abandoned Disney
attraction preventing anything normal
from getting in and anything abnormal
from getting out mobile task force Omega
17 sons of [ __ ] Khan are ever
Vigilant and maintain a strong presence
in the surrounding area but you don't
need to go anywhere for this next
anomalous Terror if you're a big
Nintendo fan it might be sitting in your
house right now Ben Drowned this haunted
NES cartridge of The Legend of Zelda
Majora's Mask contains the Restless
Spirit of its last owner a guy named Ben
who well drowned if you slot This creepy
little gaming experience into your
Nintendo Entertainment System you'll
soon find that the soul of Ben is
communicating with you directly telling
you about how he died and why his
Consciousness lingers on embedded in the
code of the game thankfully other than
the psychological trauma of experiencing
the game you're unlikely to be actually
harmed by playing it however mobile task
force beta 51 Gamers don't have rights
are still on the case they'll try to
intercept all cursed copies of the game
and then minister amnestics to anyone
who is unfortunate enough to play it
while it is still undeniably spooky it
does feel like a relief to finally find
a safe class anomaly on this list the
same can sadly not be said about our
next creature the goat man if you're a
fan of camping then this malicious mimic
is going to be your worst nightmare this
monster has existed as a fixture of
Terror in everything from a number of
Native American mythologies to iconic
4chan green text posts you may be
thinking oh What's So Scary About a goat
but this thing is no goat aside from the
fact that it's the greatest of all time
and getting you to crap your cargo
shorts in the woods first you'll smell
blood in the air and then feel an odd
electrical static like the feeling all
around you right before a lightning
strike then you'll hear noises strange
noises something not quite like a voice
like an animal throat straining to form
human words that's when you might notice
your group of friends has one more
person than you remembered and the one
thing worse than noticing that is not
noticing that because if you don't you
may end up as the shape-shifting goat
man's latest victim mobile task force
Theta 11 got your goat are constantly on
the hunt for this one but it's extreme
intelligence and ethereal nature make it
a nightmare to track but forget
nightmares to track it's time for
Laughing Jack this candy stripe clown
from hell is a really nasty customer
definitely do not engage unless you've
got a screen reality anchor on hand and
you've got a backup from members of
mobile task force Iota 40 put Jack in
the Box as a former imaginary friend
gone Rogue Laughing Jack is a
semi-intangible reality warper of
considerable power he targets his
victims with sadistic Glee pulling them
into his dark carnival to experience all
kinds of nasty tortures Laughing Jack
shows No Remorse giggling while
committing every evil act you can
imagine you'll probably only find this
clown funny if you're already a depraved
serial killer and his sense of humor is
likely to utterly break your mind unless
you've been given them nestic treatment
from the SCP Foundation this is an
anomaly that would probably get along
swimmingly with
scp-106 the old man they could chat over
a few drinks one evening and share notes
on how to cause the maximum pain to
their hapless victims that being said
few people understand maximum pain more
than the next horrifying Abomination on
our roster the Russian sleep experiment
test subjects has anyone familiar with
the work of Gru division P will tell you
the Soviets performed some pretty
horrific occult activities throughout
the 20th century one of the most
disturbing of these was the infamous
Russian sleep experiment wherein a group
of unfortunate political prisoners were
doused on a classified anomalous gas
that robbed them of their ability to
sleep a chemical compound that the
scientists hope might increase the
productivity of their workers and
Soldiers by eliminating sleep instead
over several terrifying days the
chemical and the sleep deprivation that
ensued caused the subjects to instead
become demonic monsters while current
accounts of the story suggest that all
the subjects were killed we can't say
for sure there weren't more out there
but that the experiment hasn't been
repeated as such mobile task force
Omicron 8 99 is constant only on the
lookout for freakish skeletal men
wandering through the woods never
sleeping outside the dark forests were
Siberian gulags used to be based better
safe than sorry right though of course
you won't feel safe at all if you've
spent your childhood watching scaring
media like horror movies or Eerie SCP
YouTube channels like And subscribe by
the way or scariest of all a strange
little puppet show called Candle Cove
feel a little chill go down your spine
oh yes you remember this show don't you
you love seeing all those cute little
puppets going on swashbuckling pirate
Journeys on their adorable boat the
laughing stock though there was always
that villain wasn't there you think his
name was Jawbone but that's not what you
called him you called him the skin taker
because he always had that long cloak
made of tanned human skin you also
remember that one episode that was just
all the characters screaming I mean how
could you possibly forget and most of
all you remember asking your mom about
it and are telling you that you never
actually watched a show called Candle
Cove you just sat around watching static
for hours on end of course the SCP
Foundation keeps close tabs on
everything related to this traumatic
childhood memory broadcast of the show
are seemingly impossible to contain
while the foundation can really do is
track down people who have seen it and
provide amnestic treatment though trust
us there are things that will make your
childhood far worse than just watching
Candle Cove like running into this next
iconic monster the Slenderman this
terrifying entity is powerful as he is
Iconic a shape-shifting faceless
tentacled nightmare in a three-piece
suit who likes to hide in forests and
abandoned buildings either stealing
children away or influencing their minds
until they become his proxies
Supernatural servant who do anything
they're inhuman Master asks them to the
Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of Creepypasta so the
foundation certainly has their hands
full with keeping his tentacles Under
Wraps all that mobile task force Chine
90 Marble Hornets can do is track
sightings and keep children out of the
woods when the danger of potential
Slenderman encounters arises getting him
actually contained basically seems out
of the question
after all this we might need to relax
maybe grabbing a nice sugar-free soda
and playing a session of Minecraft might
make us feel better we'll be safe there
run well probably unless we encounter
Herobrine
the SCP Foundation funnily enough is
actually no stranger to anomalies
trapped in Minecraft they've got
scp-4335 a welt in The Crucible to thank
for that but this Minecraft horror story
is a little more personal Herobrine is a
mysterious user with the Minecraft
default skin except with one difference
completely white eyes this mysterious
figure invades different Minecraft
servers acting incredibly strange
towards the people who created them what
makes this more than just some random
troll well according to Legends
Herobrine is the manifestation of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's creator
Notch naturally the foundation doesn't
want people running into ghosts on
Minecraft so they dispatch mobile task
force chai 69 blocked and reported to
quarantine any servers where Herobrine
is cited and spread misinformation that
the crafty little entity had never
actually existed in the first place what
is the truth of the situation it's
unclear and that's exactly how the
foundation likes it so there we have it
folks how the SCP Foundation would
counteract some of the most infamous
Creepypasta creeps and creatures out
there which was your favorite do we miss
any and would you like to see any of
these expanded into a full video in the
future let us know down in the comments
if you dare
[Laughter]
now go check out SCP Minecraft world
Destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in The Crucible and SCP
Edition weirdest things on Amazon Dr
Bright's great idea for more bizarre
unexpected anomalous crossovers